that led to that bucket
that ended up stealing you the game you
know big time still
by uh holiday and very fast you know i
i think the past was all about trust uh
obviously he could have pulled the ball
out
let the clock run and uh get a good shot
but he he trusted me
threw the ball out there and uh to get
the bucket so
i was gonna play by hard you have had a
big individual night in this series
chris has had a big individual night in
this series but for you
drew and chris all to get going at one
time what does that do for you
it means a lot and i think it was it was
the game for us to get going
all three of us and uh and we played
great basketball we kept our composure
even when we were down 16. we came back
from jojo we came party
you know this is the nba finals so you
got to give everything you got and uh
that's what the team did tonight
we saw you give everything you have you
had you put your hands on your knees at
the end here
chris middleton your teammate told me
that he was hoping you guys would steal
this one
to have an opportunity to win it all in
front of your fans what do you make of
that opportunity now
and one more to go one more to go we got
to play keep playing good basketball we
can't what about the outcome
just got to keep playing good basketball
and hopefully we can get a win
what do you personally task yourself
with over the next day to prepare for
arguably the biggest game of your
just career go back home enjoy a judge
on family time
uh rest just get away from basketball uh
you know what we get back here we gotta
be ready we gotta be ready as a team but
he played good basketball move the ball
good physical did what we did tonight
and uh as i said hopefully we can uh
get ourselves in a position to win the
game but we cannot worry about the
outcome right now we just got to
take care of our body and uh get back
home to our families thanks so much
giannis congratulations
mike all right malika he played 40 more
minutes 40 and a half minutes
as another huge road win they're only
six and six
on the road during the playoffs but
they've had some
critical victories including game seven